Picture the shyest female friend, relative,
or loved one you know.
A real introvert.
She can’t stand parties and playing the
dating game is her idea of a living hell.
You won’t catch her dead in a bar.
But imagine someday, everything changes: She’s
suddenly more relaxed, more outgoing.
She goes out to parties and now you keep seeing
her with this one guy - again and again and
again.
It seems like these days, all she does is
spend time with this guy.
And to think, he’s never even introduced
himself to you.
He’s practically a total stranger.
But your friend seems happy enough, so it
doesn’t bother you.
Until one day something strange happens: Your
friend just starts screaming.
You can’t explain it, she can’t explain
it, her doctor can’t explain it.
Nobody can explain it.
All you know is that, for months on end, she
has involuntary screaming fits.
Like something out of a nightmare.
But still, she always smiles.
She seems happy.
As long as you don’t look at her eyes.
There’s something oddly glassy about them.
They seem plastic.
Dead.
Your friend is experiencing a dangerous phenomenon
known to the SCP Foundation as SCP - 3512,
an anomaly that only seems to affect women
between the ages of eighteen and forty.
One woman is already dead as a result of this
and an additional nine others affected by
this strange anomaly have been catalogued
and contained in standard humanoid containment
chambers for study.
At first, the Foundation couldn’t draw any
logical conclusions for why these women were
spontaneously experiencing total personality
changes and pronounced screaming fits.
All the Foundation had to go on was that the
first cluster of infected individuals originated
in Barcelona, Spain.
A Foundation facility in Boston dispatched
one of their best field operatives, Agent
Riley Cooper, on an investigative mission
to Barcelona.
They wanted her to get to the bottom of this
phenomenon and put a stop to it before things
went any further.
While in Spain, Agent Cooper would be assisted
by a local Foundation operative, Agent Tomàs
Rey, whose intimate knowledge of the locale
would provide a key advantage
in the investigation.
Together, they’d crack this thing, and make
sure no other women were harmed.
At least, that’s what the Foundation had
hoped.
Instead, both agents disappeared under horrific
circumstances during the investigation.
And today, we’re going to tell you about
the final days of Agent Cooper and Agent Rey,
and why attempting to investigate SCP-3512
was the last thing they ever did.
Agent Cooper arrived on the fifteenth of July,
2016, and stepped out into the scorching summer
heat of Spain.
Agent Cooper was everything you’d want in
a field operative for the Foundation: Intelligent,
dedicated, and professional.
She rendezvoused with Agent Rey, who was a
comparatively smooth and laid-back figure.
The two of them began their investigation
by speaking to the friends and families of
some of the infected women, pretending to
be doctors working for the
World Health Organization.
Agent Cooper, in her personal diaries, noted
how creepy and unreal the affected women seemed.
Most of the interviews were unnerving and
sad, but not exactly enlightening.
However, as things drew to a close, a younger
sister of one of the victims mentioned a single
word “Blackout.”
Even the mention of the word caused the victim
to descend into another screaming fit.
Agent Rey’s local knowledge came in handy
once again: He recognized the name, it was
a popular local nightclub.
Agent Cooper and Agent Rey knew they had to
investigate the club, and went undercover
as regular patrons.
For the first several hours they were there,
nothing happened, but then at 2:00 AM, a man
approached Agent Cooper at the bar.
He was a tall, blond man with an unsettling
intensity to him.
He asked, without a hint of irony, what Agent
Cooper’s favorite star was.
There was something off about this man - his
word choice was too precise, almost rehearsed.
He wasn’t drunk in the slightest.
Agent Cooper intuited that this was the kind
of guy who liked to take advantage of women
in bars.
When she threw a glance at Agent Rey, signalling
to him that something was off, the stranger
quickly left.
For Agent Cooper this only further confirmed
her suspicions.
The agents paid off the bouncer to find out
if the tall stranger was a regular, and then
what his name was.
After being slipped some cash, the bouncer
was all too eager to share.
The strange man came here all the time, and
he knew his name too.
It was Josep Oriol
Agent Cooper and Agent Rey wasted no time
in finding Josep Oriol’s apartment and receiving
authorization to perform a comprehensive search
on the premises.
And as soon as they did, they found cause
to declare the man a Person of Interest in
the SCP-3512 investigation.
The apartment was a smorgasbord of suspicious
activity: Oriol was a software developer,
but he had extensive records on the architecture
of the local area - including
buildings, utilities,
and railway tunnels.
Josep correctly figured the investigators
were coming for him, and had fled his home
before they could get there.
And this was only the tip of the iceberg.
Agents Cooper and Rey then found a book with
a plain cover sitting on Oriol’s kitchen
table - Cooper thought it was a publisher’s
proof, a kind of pre-publication prototype
copy of a book.
They collected it but didn’t read it straightaway,
worrying about its potentially cognitohazardous
nature.
And besides, they were a little distracted
by the home-made monstrosity sitting next
to it.
It looked to Agent Cooper like a sculpted
blob of wax, with a series of twelve makeshift
legs made from a variety of substances including
Lego pieces, rose stems, a crab claw, a corkscrew.
Rey called Cooper into the bathroom, where
there were a number of boxes filled with similar
supplies: Bodkins, quills, doll's limbs, wire,
and syringes.
When Cooper led Rey back into the kitchen
to see Oriol’s little art project, later
classified by the Foundation as SCP-3512-1,
they were surprised and unnerved to see that
it was already gone.
Everything about this
situation screamed “anomalous”,
and it only got worse later that night, when
Cooper actually read the book she’d collected
from Oriol’s apartment, being sure to wear
cognitohazard-filtering goggles as a precaution.
The book, now known to the
Foundation as SCP-3512-2,
was entitled “The More You Know: A Pick-Up
Artist’s Bible”, and was written by a
man using the pen name “Enigma.”
As the title suggests, it was a misogynistic,
625 page non-fiction book on the subject of
picking up women.
It even had a foreword on its effectiveness
by popular American rapper Calvin Broadus
Jr., better known as Snoop Dogg, though after
being contacted by the Foundation, Mr. Dogg
claimed no knowledge of the book.
The book began with your typical creepy and
dehumanizing seduction tactics for the first
eleven chapters, but the following twelve
chapters which were each entitled “Chapter
Twelve” delved into increasingly creepy
and esoteric techniques including advanced
geometric proofs, the interpretation of dreams,
do-it-yourself surgical techniques, symbolism
in architecture, and anomalous rituals.
The book's afterword is composed of more than
15,000 anagrams of the book's title, laid
out in spiral and triangular patterns.
Cooper took a particular morbid interest in
Chapter 18, where it appeared
to provide instructions
on creating objects that looked like the anomalous
SCP-3512-1 sculptures found in Oriel’s apartment.
The chapter read:
“Make a rough ball of the materials you've
harvested, and place it in the freezer for
6-12 hours.
Pork fat can be used, but
will have less satisfactory
results.
Who knew, right?
While you wait, you can prepare the limbs.
Concentrate on articulation rather than strength.
You may want to add simple tools to some limbs,
if the object of your desire is more careful
than most, but remember that the more complicated
you make them, the more precise your sculpting
will need to be.
Lay your prepared limbs out on a clean, flat
surface.
Once your adipose preparation has had time
to freeze, carefully carve it into the shape
you learned in Chapter Twelve.
You will know it is ready when you see it
start smiling at you.
Now introduce the limbs - they should "take"
almost immediately.
Wait until your intended is likely to be sleeping,
then concentrate your thoughts on her face,
and particularly the inside of her mouth and
throat.
Soon you'll see your new friend scurry off,
ready to help you establish social dominance...”
If this wasn’t disturbing enough, the next
chapter advised the using scissors in the
removal of the aspiring-seductionist’s pinkie
finger, as well as the pinkie fingers of their
family members, to help increase their seductive
power.
It appeared to Cooper that these rituals and
seemingly living anomalous sculptures were
behind the SCP-3512 phenomena, and that night,
they got their next break in the case.
The two agents had sent the architectural
plans found in Oriol’s apartment back to
Foundation HQ, and while most of it was found
to be public records of the local area, there
was one notable abnormality: A secret exit
in a little used subway tunnel that led to
a grand spiral staircase, heading down to...Well,
they just didn’t know, and if was the job
of Agents Cooper and Rey to find out.
They set out later that night, on what they
didn’t know would be the last mission they’d
ever take...
The two agents descended the spiral staircase
for what felt like hours until they reached
an elaborate system of tunnels at the bottom.
They began exploring the tunnels and found
that they were cramped, and covered in strange,
ritualistic carvings.
Occasionally, they even saw clusters of human
pinkie fingers sticking out of the wall.
They kept going and soon found that whatever
they were moving towards was loud, immensely
hot, and the smell was truly horrific.
As the almost deafening mechanical drone got
louder and louder and the smell grew worse,
they knew they must be getting closer to whatever
was happening here.
.
The tunnel soon opened up into a giant chamber
where they found something horrific.
In front of them was what looked to be an
entire river of bubbling, liquid human fat
- the exact kind that the author Enigma had
recommenced using to create the mind-altering
SCP-3512-1 sculptures in his book.
And speaking of the book, across the river
Agent Cooper and Agent Rey noticed a complex
series of printing presses, presumably churning
out more copies of “The More You Know: A
Pick-Up Artist’s Bible” to spread its
anomalous influence far and wide.
However, before the duo could literally stop
the presses, they were attacked.
A huge 3512-1 entity with legs made out of
human spines, jumped down from the ceiling.
It latched onto Agent Cooper, embedding her
in its waxy body and dragging her into the
disgusting river of hot fat.
Agent Rey was separated and lost in the tunnels;
presumed dead, as he hasn’t been seen since.
Agent Cooper, however, would live to see a
far more horrifying fate.
She was carried downriver by the greasy tide
until her body was washed up in a different
chamber that looked to be a place of worship
below the Sagrada Familia Basilica, filled
with thousands of tiny, crawling 3512-1s.
There, she met the creator of all this: A
horrific thing that was perhaps once a man,
now covered in wriggling, living pinkie fingers
sticking out of its body.
It was disgusting, but she wouldn’t mind
for long.
WIn fact, the next time Cooper woke up, she
didn’t have a problem with it at all.
She was changed, just like all the others.
Another victim of the SCP-3512 phenomenon.
She was giggly, outgoing, and uninhibited,
all despite the nightmarish situation she
was in.
She loved the horrifying monster that had
done this to her.
She didn’t have a choice not to.
And when he was tired of her, he took her
and threw her down into a large pit in his
chamber, the same one where the many dead
bodies of his previous
mind-controlled “girlfriends”
were laying.
Neither Agent was ever seen again after this.
Mobile Task Force Zeta-9, aka "Mole Rats",
have been sent into the tunnels to investigate,
but they didn’t find any of the locations
comparable to the ones seen by Cooper and
Rey in their last hours.
Whoever did all this is still out there.
Still dangerous.
So ladies, if ever you see a guy you know
reading a copy of “The More You Know: A
Pick-Up Artist’s Bible”, run like your
life and sanity depends on it - because this
time, it really, really does.
Now go check out “SCP - 001 - The Children
- Ouroborous Cycle” and “SCP - 4999 - Someone
To Watch Over Us Tale” for more records
of mysterious phenomena from the SCP Foundation.